GOP debate last night um honestly I
didn't know that there was even going to
be a debate until it was already
happening but then I did tune in for a
bit and uh look I'll be honest I
basically analyze these debates the same
way everybody analyzes them and you will
generally like the performances of the
candidates that you like and you will
dislike the performances of the
candidates you you dislike um and so
that's that's really what every pundit
is saying when they're offering their
analysis they may use more words to say
it but it's really just I liked this
person I like and I didn't like this
person who I didn't like and to that end
I thought the santis performed well I
thought he uh proved again why he would
be a fantastic president he was thorough
reasonable articulate thoughtful
competent admittedly again I already
thought that going
in and uh then I watched the debate and
DeSantis was Dan santis and uh I
approve uh I thought Nikki Haley on the
other hand was shrill and insufferable
and just aw all around I thought Tim
scottt was was whatever a big meh well
that's not true he did Tim Scott did
have one
moment he doesn't have a lot of
memorable moments he's kind of he's like
designed to never uh uh have a memorable
moment that's his whole strategy for
better or worse mostly for worse but he
did have one notable moment one moment
to remember um here he is calling for us
to attack Iran let's watch that you have
to strike in Iran if you want to make a
difference you cannot just continue to
have strikes in Syria on warehouses you
actually have to cut off the head of the
snake and the head of the snake is Iran
and not simply their proxies in order
for us to have a powerful
response from America we have to be in a
position of strength as president of
United States my foreign policy is
simple you cannot negotiate with evil
you have to destroy it
okay so there you go that was um that
was one notable moment from Tim Scott a
memorable moment unfortunately memorable
for all the wrong reasons he's casually
suggesting that we set off World War III
essentially calling for the deaths of
millions because that's what World War
III would mean and his logic doesn't
even make any sense I mean cut off the
head of the snake so we bomb Iran and
then the snake is
dead is that simple
huh no more enemies in the world no more
troubles in the Middle East just bomb
Iran you know we we've been doing a lot
of bombing for the last 30 years but uh
you know you know what we it hasn't
solved anything yet but you know what
would really solve this more bombing we
just we need to set a few more bombs and
that'll do
it so this is the 2004 era republicanism
that we get from Tim Scott and we
especially get from Nikki Haley who is
Boomer Conan incarnate uh George Bush
except unlikable and annoying and she
also needs work on her uh she needs to
work on her comebacks a little bit so
there was a moment in the debate where
VC said that Nikki Haley is Dick Cheney
in three-inch heels which is a great
line and also true and Haley didn't have
much of a response in person but then on
Twitter she posted this she
says VC I wear heels they're not a
fashion statement therefore
ammunition now let's think about that
from moment let's consider this because
her team had time to Workshop this right
this was not this is not in the moment
they they put this on Twitter they
thought about it they crafted it and
then they posted it and this is what
they came up what does it
mean what is it supposed to mean I
really can't make I'm actually not sure
I'm not playing dumb I don't know what
the punchline is supposed to be your
heels are
ammunition what do you mean because you
want to send them to to Ukraine is that
I mean what do you mean how do you how
do you use your heels as ammunition do
do you know what ammunition
is it's bizarre and there was another
Haley moment that was kind of uh
flabbergasting also Haley Haley has been
critical of VC because VC has a Tik Tok
account and VC responded in the debate
by pointing out that Nikki Haley though
she uh is very critical of Tik Tok and
critical of him for having one that her
own daughter is on Tik Tok talk and uh
Nikki Hy had a rather strong response to
that um let's
listen Mr ramaswami uh we've talked
about this you campaign on Tik Tock how
do you get Tik Tock ban if you use it
well I I I want to laugh at why Nikki
Haley didn't answer your question which
is about looking at families in the eye
in the last debate she made fun of me
for actually joining Tik Tok while her
own daughter was actually using the app
for a long time so you might want to
take care of your family
first adult daughter the next generation
of Americans are using it and that's
actually the point you have her
supporters crapping her up that's fine
here's the truth the easy answer is
actually to say that we're just going to
ban one app we got to go further we have
to ban any us company actually
transferring us data to the Chinese
here's a story most people don't know
Airbnb hands over us user data to the
CCP
now that's a us-owned company so this is
the problem when you have Republicans
that temporarily go the way the winds
blow and now it's popular to talk tough
on China when she was UN Ambassador
called them literally her words not mine
our great friend you can't be
Fairweather fans of the right policy get
to the root cause even us companies in
Silicon Valley are regularly doing it
cut the virtue signaling the fact of the
matter is Democrats are on Tik Tok today
the only person one of the few people
who is putting up content the way the
actual algor GM's work speaking for
pro-israel views or others is more
Republicans will join it but stop us
companies from turning over data to
Chinese
companies don't get to okay
so you heard maybe you heard her say
there uh you're just scum you are scum
now first of all the Vex point is valid
it's a valid point and this kind of of
foe outrage is pretty absurd this thing
it it you I roll my eyes at it this
thing where we
pretend that it's it's way out of bounds
to ever mention a candidate's family
member under any circumstance leave the
families out of it never mention the
family come on he he was not attacking
her daughter he didn't criticize the
daughter he's making a point that
involved her daughter which I think is
fine and it's a valid
point you know and and these politicians
like they they bring their families up
on stage right they show their families
up and then if anybody even mentions the
family how dare you don't mention I this
is none of your business what do you got
to open stage for like
clearly uh clearly you want it to be
people's business you just want uh you
want people to say certain things now I
don't think that you should be attacking
the child of a candidate unless they
become an actual surrogate for the you
know if if if the child who's an adult
becomes a surrogate for the candidate
well then that's fair game I don't think
Nikki Hilly's daughter is a surrogate
but there's nothing wrong with
mentioning her existence in the process
of making a point give me a
break um and it certainly doesn't
justify calling somebody
scum I mean scum is that
that's Haley is is ruthless towards VC
right I mean absolutely ruthless here's
my question have you ever heard her
speak that way to anybody on the left
because I'd almost be okay if this was
kind of how she is and she's just coming
out launching like she will you come
after her she's going to rip you to
shreds she goes after her opponents
tears them apart if that was kind of her
way of doing
things then I still don't think it's
appropriate to call somebody scum in
that context but at least it would um
put it into context a little bit but she
never when you when have you ever heard
her say anything CL close to that about
somebody on the other side scum has she
ever called a Democrat scum ever called
anyone on the left
scum you know the people that are out
there killing babies and butchering
children and castrating kids like has
she ever called any of them
scum and it also shows by the way that
if you get that
rattled I mean if you're that rattled
and you get that emotional because
somebody makes some point about Tik Tok
then you're not cut out for them you
cannot be president you're too emotional
you're too easily
rattled but that wasn't nearly as bad as
this tweet that she sent out during the
debate she was uh doing a lot of
tweeting during the debate somehow and
she also tweeted this she says there
would be no Hamas without Iran it's not
that Israel needs America America needs
Israel this is not the first time we've
heard her say
this first of all it's not even remotely
true what are you talking about you
really expect us to believe that America
benefits more from its Alliance than
Israel
benefits from that same Alliance that is
nonsense no Israel greatly benefits from
America and and and besides if this was
true then doesn't that undercut your
entire argument for helping Israel said
this not the first time she said this
multiple times she has says well Israel
doesn't need us we need
them if that's true then how can you say
that in one breath and then in the next
breath tell us that it is imperative for
the United States to help Israel I
thought you said they don't need us I
they don't need us at all we could not
exist according to you and it would make
a
difference you you cannot say both of
those things you cannot say they
desperately need us and also they don't
need us a few decades ago private
citizens used to be largely that private
the internet has changed everything
though think about everything you've
browsed searched for watched or tweeted
now imagine all of that data being C
called through collected and aggregated
by Third parties into a permanent public
record your record having your private
life exposed for others to see was once
something that only celebrities worried
about but in an era where everyone is
public everyone is a public figure
that's why I keep my data private when I
go online I turn to express VPN did you
know there are hundreds of data Brokers
out there whose sole businesses to buy
and sell your data the worst part is
that they uh don't have to tell you who
they're selling it to or get your
consent one of these data points is your
IP address data Harvesters use your IP
to uniquely identify you and your
locations but with expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and my IP address is
masked every time I turn expressvpn on
I'm given a random IP address shared by
other expressvpn customers that makes it
more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data the best
part is how easy expressvpn is to use no
matter what device you're on phone
laptop Smart TV all you got to do is tap
one button to get protected so if like
me you believe that your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN on the market Mar visit
expressvpn.com Walsh use my link to get
three extra months free that's exp rsvpn
docomo expressvpn.com
Walsh but if you own a firearm then you
need to check out stopboxusa they just
introduced the stopbox pro the new safe
is the most reliable secure place for
your firearm stopbox Pro is larger
stronger and more versatile crafted from
durable glass reinforced polycarbon ABS
it's uh not just tough it's smart you
don't want to be fumbling with with keys
or electronic codes and high stress
situations the stopbox pro patented hand
gesture code lock allows quick intuitive
access without batteries Electronics
they understand the critical balance
between security and accessibility
that's why the stopbox pro is designed
to be lowprofile and portable whether at
home or traveling your firearm remains
concealed secure yet readily accessible
as well stopbox pro has an expanded
range of 81 combination possibilities
making it more customizable than ever
plus an enhanced surface texture for a
better grip and the improved locking
mechanism is a breeze to operate don't
compromise on safety and accessibility
visit stopbox usa.com use promo code
Matt for 10% off your order experience
the Peace of Mind stopbox Springs that's
stopbox usa.com use promo code Matt for
10% off your order and aside from that
it's this is this is it's an insane way
to speak about your own country nobody
talks like this about their own country
outside of America America do you think
Israelis say this kind of thing about
Israel they don't need us we need them
this is not how people talk about their
own
countries this is a uniquely modern
American phenomenon it's like a sickness
a mental sickness where some of our
leaders or would be leaders profess
greater admiration and love for and
pride in foreign countries than their
own it's just a crazy thing to say again
you don't you go especially anywhere
outside of the you know outside of uh
the Western World in
particular and you're not going to ever
hear this kind of
thing it's your country you're supposed
to say yeah they need us we're important
like that's how you're supposed to feel
about your own country you don't put
another country above
yours especially if you want to be in
charge of
it now um as for VC there was one moment
of his that uh um is making the rounds
and I think everyone agrees it's kind of
his best moment let's watch that romis
Swami let me turn to you please make
your case why would you uh why should
you be the nominee and not the former
president I think there's something
deeper going on in the Republican party
here and I am upset about what happened
last night we've become a party of
losers at the end of the day is a cancer
in the Republican establishment let
speak the truth I mean since Ron
McDaniel took over as chairwoman of the
RNC in 2017 we have lost 2018 2020 2022
no red wave that never came we got
trounced last night in 2023 and I think
that we have to have accountability in
our party for that matter R if you want
to come on stage tonight you want to
look the GOP voters in the eye and tell
them you resign I will turn over my
yield my time to you and frankly look
the people they are cheering for losing
in the Republican Party think about
who's moderating this debate this should
be Tucker Carlson Joe Rogan and Elon
Musk we'd have 10 times the viewership
asking questions that GOP Primary voters
actually care about and bringing more
people into our party you think the
Democrats and we got Christian weler
here you think the Democrats would
actually hire Greg Gutfeld to to a
democratic debate they wouldn't do it
and so the fact of the matter is I mean
Christ I'm going to use this time
because this is actually about you in
the media and the corrupt media
establishment ask you the Trump Russia
collusion hoax that you pushed on this
network for years was that real or was
that Hillary Clinton made up
disinformation answer the question go Mr
Rob this is how we get our country
back we need accountability because this
media rigged the 2016 election they
rigged the 2020 election with the hunter
Biden laptop story and they're going to
rig this election time is up let me turn
to governor governor
Chris uh so it's a great moment and um
uh matter how you feel about the or who
whoever you support you you have to
admit it's a it's a good moment
exactly what needs to be said going on
offense attacking the Republican
establishment the media which is what
needs to happen but but doing
it let me actually clarify that because
attacking the Republican establishment
in the media that's easy everyone does
that okay that so we just in Broad terms
saying oh the establishment of the media
they're so mean that's the kind of thing
that everybody says and every Republican
says even Republicans in the
establishment will'll say things like
that um but what they won't do most of
the time is name names first of
all uh so they'll they'll speak in Broad
terms about the Republican establishment
but you'll notice that it's like the
establishment is this amorphous organism
sort of it's like this um blob like
thing out there and it has no name or
face and that's how we talk about it um
no The Establishment is comprised of
actual ual people and you should be
calling those people out calling them
out to their face Ron McDaniel was in
the audience Vette called her out called
out the media again you know you you
call it the media in general everyone
does that or you can put them on the
spot you know
specifically we on NBC call out NBC
specifically it's exactly what should
happen um and he's absolutely correct
about Ron McDaniel by the way the RNC
chair she has been a disaster lost after
loss after loss under her tenure it is
it is speaking of insane the fact that
she still has a job and but but here's
the thing she mostly escapes
criticism because Trump endorsed her she
is Trump's pick which again shows that
Trump is he still absolutely sucks in
the Personnel Department he hasn't
gotten better at that H but because he
backed her and continues to back her
even as she fails in every conceivable
way um you know even many of the people
people who normally would be eager to to
criticize establishment figures like Ron
McDaniel will not criticize her because
she's Trump's
person what are what are her successes
can you name one name just one like C
can you fill in the blank Ron McDaniel
has done a great job
with what with with Phil anything is
there anything that she's done well or
even serviceably like has she done a
serviceable Ron mcdel has done a service
serviceable job with fill in the
blank you can't do it um so all that was
correct and this is why ultimately VC if
anybody wins the debate it's VC um and I
know you might say if you watch the
whole debate you'll say well there are
other great moments that you know this
was just one moment he would doesn't
matter the other other moments don't
matter because this is the moment people
are talking about in the next day like
in a debate there's going to be one or
two moments at most that people talk
about once the debate is
over rarely is there going to be a
moment that they talk about like a day
after it's over or two days after um
whoever gets that moment wins like it's
as simple as that debate should be more
substantive than that there should be
more to it than that you know how I feel
about the way these debates are
conducted in the first place and the
fact that it all boils down to um boils
down to these you know clippable sound
bites and stuff it it shouldn't work
that way but it does right now and
that's a especially the case because
Trump isn't there like It ultimately Pro
the debates uh unfortunately probably
don't matter I don't think they make
much of a dent in the polls because
Trump is the guy out
ahead and in order to get in order to
take some ground from him you got to
land some blows on him but it's but as
we've discovered it's just hard to land
a blow if he's not there which is why
he's not there
obviously um but
if there's any way to win if there's any
way to you know make something out of
the debate and have it help your
campaign then you have to have a moment
you could have a good debate and have
great answers and everything is fine and
that's okay and then you you know it
doesn't hurt you but you leave and
you're just sort of it's it's it's like
it's like a never happened it might as
well have not happened um but if you
want to have it actually help you then
you need to have a moment and uh so had
really you know they most people will
say well you got to watch the debate to
know who won it I think I think if
anything you need to not watch the
debate to know who want it's it's the
person who wins it it's like what are
people what are the clips that are
circulating the next day who are people
talking about you go to Twitter you go
to Facebook or whatever who who's all
over the feed that's the person who won
it doesn't matter what else like the
rest of it doesn't exist anymore in the
public mind might it might as well have
not happened it doesn't
matter I'm not telling you how how I
think it should be I'm just telling you
how it
is and so I go on Twitter like last
night and VC is pretty much the only
people only person anyone's talking
about from the debate because of that
moment and a couple of others so he wins
uh what will that mean in the end will
it uh make any difference I don't know
but that's how you win you gota you got
to have the moments you have to have
them hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans you there